[Música]
ya lo veníamos discutiendo es el triunfo
de la izquierda en colombia la primera
vez que este país va a tener un gobierno
de izquierda y lo logró el candidato
gustavo petro que llegaba a las
elecciones por una colisión conocida
como el pacto histórico por eso hoy en
directo nos quedamos en la capital
colombiana para analizar porque la
llegada de petro es histórica para
colombia y también en latinoamérica y
los gobiernos de izquierda por eso me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
periodista de france 24 andrés
granadillo andrés bienvenido porque
podemos decir que un hombre como gustavo
petro está llegando al país a hacer
historia como el primer gobierno de
izquierda pues la llegada de gustavo
petro valentín a un hombre sin abolengos
ni apellidos es un evento sin
precedentes en colombia
así llega a la presidencia a una persona
considerada del pueblo un exguerrillero
que entregó las armas hace 30 años un
poco más de 30 años y red se reincorporó
a la vida civil eso lo convierte en un
fenómeno un fenómeno político sin
precedentes además ya había aspirado a
la presidencia en dos oportunidades otro
factor es que colombia es un país
tradicionalmente conservador y fue mucho
tiempo bipartidista el izquierdista en
colombia siempre la izquierda en
colombia siempre ha sido satanizada
debido a que se la asocia a guerrillas
que eran claramente de izquierda como
las farc como lo es el ln y muchas otras
que se han levantado en armas en
colombia nunca ha llegado al poder un
gobierno progresista como el que propone
petro aunque ha habido presidentes que
tienen a la centroizquierda pero siempre
han pertenecido al establecimiento y
esas familias que han gobernado el país
durante doscientos años la fórmula
vicepresidencial francia marc es una
mujer afro o lideresa social ex empleada
del servicio doméstico madre de cabeza
de familia es algo que nunca había
ocurrido en colombia ni se vislumbraba
hace poco tiempo bueno y andrés como han
sido las tendencias políticas de
latinoamérica cómo está el panorama
político en la región porque sabemos que
una gran parte de américa latina en este
momento tiene una presencia de la
izquierda en los ejecutivos pues
latinoamérica está viviendo una ola
política que la está llevando
precisamente hacia la izquierda en
suramérica brasil ecuador paraguay
uruguay son los únicos países que tienen
gobernantes de derecha en colombia habrá
que esperar hasta el 7 de agosto para
que el país pase a este grupo de la
izquierda igual en américa central sólo
guatemala costa rica y panamá tienen
gobiernos de derecha mientras que la
fuerza mexicana está dirigida desde él
desde el 2018 por el izquierdista hambre
es un fenómeno que ha venido en ascenso
en los últimos años debido a la débil
economía
altas tasas de desempleo el descontento
hacia la clase dirigente y en última
medida pero no menos importante la
gestión de la pandemia que ha dejado más
empobrecidos a los pueblos en esta
región del mundo
la desigualdad es galopante y las
personas buscan alternativas de cambio
en políticas más sociales en inversión
de infraestructura como hospitales con
la ilusión de que haya más empleo las
clases menos favorecidas son las que
terminan volcándose a las urnas al
sentir y vivir un descontento por la
falta de ingresos y oportunidades
pero si las izquierdas latinoamericanas
han sido moderadas también hay otras
extremistas como la de chávez en
venezuela o de castro en cuba y que han
causado mucho temor en el continente
valentina